foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
coming up on tonight's program
serious politics is back also they say
after seeing our forest Johnson and Liz
trust how will labors kirst armor deal
with Rishi sunak
the home office process just four
percent of Asylum claims last year but
will the department manage to support
anyone even Sue Ella braveman came back
straight to her old job
don't ask don't tell James cleverly
warns gay football fans they'll have to
make some compromises if they go to the
World Cup in Qatar
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Kate McCann and Harry
Cole
good evening from London and welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored With Me Kate
McCann and the political editor of the
sun Harry Cole filling in for Piers who
is still on his sunbed out in La I'm
still waiting for that call from Rishi
sunak well Harry look both of us were in
the Press Gallery today for pmqs what
was your take from wish you soon next
first outing well I don't think it could
have gone better for him he had uh for
the first time I can remember since
about 2019 the Tory bench is absolutely
roaring behind him he was polished he
was a smoothie a complete contrast to
either sort of bumbling performance
Boris Johnson used to do or the slightly
Meek performance of Liz truss and I have
to say kyostarma was in a bit of a
pickle because he tried to throw lots of
different lines at uh at new pm to see
what would stick I'm not sure any of
them did the only fly in the ointment I
would say is that um the appointment of
suela Braven I think is going to come
back and haunt Richie soon act
throughout his early days of his Tanya
yeah well let's just have a look at how
Rishi neck dealt with the moment when
kirstama brought up the appointment of
the Home Secretary
the homes actually made an error of
judgment but she recognized that she
raised the matter and she accepted her
mistake and that's why that's why I was
delighted to welcome back into a United
cabinet that brings experience
and stability to the heart of government
they go I mean he's talking there about
bringing experience back but what we
know really is that it's about party
unity and there are some people who
suggest that behind the scenes a deal
was done between the two of them that
she was always going to walk back into
that job yeah I thought it was quite
amusing that uh the new premises stood
on the steps of Downing Street yesterday
and said he was going to be above Party
politics all of that's gone away and
integrity was going to be at every
single level of his government and the
first thing he does is as you say cut a
backroom deal to a point to appoint the
uh the Home Secretary who is off the
rise of the party it was crucial in
getting rid of Boris Johnson's attempt
to come back at the weekend and we
understand tonight that senior civil
servants were arguing against that
appointment so one of the first things
the new prime minister has done having
after all the mess of the of the last
few years has actually gone on an issue
of Integrity overall advice and
appointed someone deeply controversial
yeah do you think he's going to be able
to get over that decision or is it going
to dog him he's in quite a powerful
position now and I don't think there
would be many to shed if he had to lose
her one more time yeah well that
question of Sue Ella braveman is one of
course that came up again and again in
prime minister's questions and let's get
the government's view on that because
joining us now from Westminster is
transport Minister Lucy Fraser lovely to
have you with us this evening
I want to start by asking about that pmq
session because we heard Rishi sunak
there defending his decision to
reappoint the Home Secretary but it has
come up a number of times since is six
days enough time do you think when a
minister has made such a big mistake
admitted to its shared cabinet level
secret documents on a private email
address to then be re-admitted to one of
the top jobs in the land
well I think you saw the prime
minister's position on that very clearly
and you've just done the clip you know
she she made an error of judgment and
she apologized for it she admitted her
mistake
um she brought it to the attention of
the cabinet secretary and she resigned
uh and so she she had a consequence for
that but you know there was a new
government that was appointed and Rishi
has appointed him as he was entitled to
do in in that reshuffle and Harry
mentioned about experience I mean I
think we should remember that suela does
in fact have a great deal of experience
she's been the Attorney General she was
a barrister so she steeped in Justice
and she is a good appointment for Home
Secretary on that basis hi Lizzy it's
one of the most important jobs in
government the the classified secret
information that goes across the home
secretary's desk it would shock any of
us are you really comfortable with one
of your colleagues feeling the need to
email that round uh just to ask for
advice ignoring all the usual channels
it's completely not on isn't it
well obviously it's not my decision but
what I can tell you is that all
ministers have to go through uh
professional ethics assessments before
they are appointed they aren't appointed
if that if that ethics assessment throws
up something so she will I am confident
and sure
um have been through the uh professional
ethics
um are you comfortable though with the
Prime Minister seeming to ignore senior
civil servants and their advice on
private Gene ethics
I'm sorry I missed that Harry are you
comfortable with your new prime minister
seeming to ignore senior civil servants
advice on ethics
well I'm not sure what the situation is
with what advice was given
um how that was taken but what I can
tell you is that the Prime Minister
um has uh acted as he uh as he can do he
will have she will have gone through
that ethics assessment and I went with
Rishi for a year and I can tell you uh
that from my perspective he is uh he has
integrity and professionalism in Spades
well you said he's done what he can do
but of course he could have appointed
somebody else to be home secretary but
let's move on because lots of people
around the country will be wondering
tonight given that the government has
moved the date of the financial
statement back by a couple of weeks that
gives you enough time to find a way to
solve the 35 billion pound black hole
that you have in the public finances how
do you plan to do that
okay I was a minister in the treasury
and as you will know and I'm sure very
ministers have said to you can't it
would be inappropriate uh even if I knew
all the details to identify what will be
in the fiscal statement well all right
let's try another one will you be
keeping the triple lock in place in that
statement
well the Prime Minister was asked that
today and I I think he uh answered
entirely accurately if we look at what
he has done in the past he has always
been there for people who need it he's
you know we saw that during uh covid
with the furlough scheme we saw that
with his energy package it was one of
the things that he identified uh that he
was going to continue in relation to uh
the the former prime minister you know
he congratulated Liz on her energy
support so I think he will be looking
after people but for the details of that
I'm afraid you're going to have to wait
for the statement Lucy a week ago the
chancellor said the triple lock was up
for grabs potentially on the table he
was then last Wednesday overall by the
Prime Minister the then prime minister
who said actually no it's secure now
today the number 10 of the treasury is
saying that they won't make that they
won't confirm that so should pensioners
go to bed tonight worried about what
they're going to get next year or not
well there will be a fiscal statement on
the 17th of November it's not far away
and we will see all the details then
another big issue tonight is migration
um is the prime minister going to have
an answer for the other great debate
that was going on in the previous
administration a week ago about whether
net migration should go up or down if it
can get growth going where do you stand
on that
uh well the government's position is
um that it is really important that we
do tackle uh illegal immigration to this
country and that's what the Home
Secretary Zola Braverman is absolutely
committed to and I know that the prime
minister is committed to that as well
but we also do need to ensure that we
have the necessary skills for people who
need to work in some Industries here so
your obviously the numbers go up
I think the prime minister is committed
to ensuring that we tackle uh and uh the
issue of immigration illegal immigration
uh and I know that he's going to do uh
and he's very is committed to ensuring
in particular we tackle the issue in
relation to the channel boats uh
Crossings
um that uh where those numbers are
rising unfortunately uh all the time
but let's just separate those two issues
out because what we were just asking you
about was the overall number of people
who are coming into the country in
relation to growth many people say if
you increase the number of people who
come into the UK who take up jobs here
then that will grow the economy pretty
quickly that's something that Rishi Cena
is going to need to do a reference back
to that 35 billion pound black hole are
you saying that net migration should go
up or down tonight
well there's a balance in relation to
immigration isn't it and I know that
what one of the things that Rishi was
very committed to when he was the
chancellor was ensuring that people here
are trained in the skills that we need
for those jobs he put together a
significant package of support for
employers and employees boot camps
upskilling he was looking at the time he
was Chancellor about how we could
support employers to give more skills to
their employees so I know that he will
look at that as well
Harry's trying to let you get away too
soon there just finally I want to ask
you about some comments that James
cleverley has made today on Qatar he has
said that people lgbtq people who are
traveling to Qatar need to be respectful
of the country's cultural norms are you
comfortable with what he said because it
has upset some people
I think what what James was talking
about was uh he what he was saying and
as a foreign secretary he will be
extremely acute of is the government
always raises issues in relation to
Human Rights and and and people's rights
with countries directly and I'm sure he
does that as foreign secretary with
countries across the world but what he
was saying in addition to that was that
you know when people do go to various
countries of course they need to respect
the laws of those countries
Lucy Fraser thank you for joining us
this evening
well let's bring in tonight's pack we
have the man who was the conservative
party chairman for 50 days sir Jake
Berry and lifelong associate editor of
the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire Kevin
what do you make of that
Lucy was as clear as mud that's
absolutely appalling wasn't it I mean
look she doesn't know or can't say
because she doesn't want to contradict
it I mean look you look at the question
of the triple lock it was in it was out
it was in it it was out it's like a
horkie Corky they that appointment of
the Home Secretary after a security
breach sort of flying the ointment it's
a snarling Rottweiler that is going to
bite the Prime Minister he's a huge era
of misjudgment that he's created a
problem for his own back I mean it's
she couldn't then she couldn't answer
her on migration what is the
government's position on migration when
I go up does it want to go down stay the
same what is the answer I mean you've if
you've come in as a new prime minister
and a fresh start and you're going to
restore order after the instability of
uh Liz truss then what a terrible start
if only somebody had written a book
hurry up
we can pre-order it yeah yeah the link
will be at the bottom um Jake we're
going to come back to you to talk about
you losing your job very shortly but I
mean what did you make of that interview
because richardsonac is in a difficult
position when it comes to his home
secretary but more to the point some of
these really big questions we still
can't get the answers to well look we
heard yesterday from the Prime Minister
that he's going to implement the
conservative party Manifesto who said it
on the the steps of Downing Street so
there's good and bad bits of that
there's good and bad bits of that Kate
so it means that you can keep that
mandate by 19 million people that Boris
Johnson won but it also means on things
like the triple lock and tax Rises that
you're gonna have to stick with what
that Manifesto said let's just remind
everyone no new tax risers and
protection of the triple lock and I when
I was advising the former prime minister
about what we do on the triple lock I
pointed out to her that you know
everyone's so clever in the treasury but
apparently none of them can count
because you have to be able to get the
right number of conservative MPS to go
through the lobby to vote down the
triple lock and I don't think that'll
happen on on votes Jake one of the last
actions the government you served in was
to try and whip through a decision on
restarting fracking in the UK that
wasn't in the 2019 Manifesto do you
think that was a good idea well I did
actually I've always been quite Sport
and fracking you say that even as a
Lancashire MP and the reason is I don't
think someone who lives in
buckinghamshire or wherever it may be in
the far south somewhere should have a
say over whether we have fracking in
Lancashire I'm quite happy for my local
residents to have their say I think
they'll all say no but I want them to
have their say if we want to be a
Sovereign Nation we have to accept that
we cannot be safe and secure without
being self-sufficient in terms of energy
we cannot have another situation where a
hostile Nation holders to Ransom so my
view is let's go ahead with fracking I
know it's not a government policy but
I've come on to give you my view
let people decide I believe I believe in
democracy to pause it again well it's
the prime minister's decision to make
but you know I believe in democracy but
he's sticking to the manifesto again
isn't he because it's the manifesto in
2019 said no fracking and then all of a
sudden we're going to have fries
I know I know the number of times has
been broken which is pretty frequently
I mean the question really now for labor
is how do they counter Rishi sunak
because it's the first outing today I
mean lots of people suggesting that
kistama tried a good game but didn't
quite manage to land a blow on the new
prime minister uh well I think he did on
the Home Secretary
uh I think pensions that was the SMP but
we can see there's a problem there I
think he landed a blow you might say
it's Sly or non-doms uh drawn attention
to the Chancellor's vast wealth where
he's about to make cuts on ordinary
working people and that is going to be
very hard for somebody who was a 222nd
richest person in the country with his
wife you know twice the wealth of the
king 730 million to then to then be
telling people on low wages to tighten
the belt well Labor's got an interesting
position on this because we understand
that secure Stamford told his party not
to talk about Rishi sunax vast wealth
and not to talk about the politics of
Envy as it has been called but Richard
Bergen stood up today and said you know
he's 200 was it 200 000 times richer
than a nurse I mean clearly the party is
not United it's not 200 000 times richer
than Kirsten king of Stormer is
comfortable unquestionably because he
run the crown prosecution service was
director of public prosecutions but
Rishi sunak is the country's richest
ever prime minister in history now that
would not be a problem if he was going
to play it Father Christmas but he was
going to be Scrooge and he's going to be
taking away your income he's going to be
running down your services that will
become a big problem for that prime
minister another big round of the day
James Cleveland's comments about
traveling landscape plants going to
Qatar do you think he got that right do
you think he was you know should people
be respecting culture what does
compromise actually mean yeah I suppose
James cleverley is probably trotting out
the line When in Rome do what the Romans
do but having been a cat or a couple of
times and seeing how oppressive the
police can be this is a World Cup if you
can normally go oh well cup you're gay
uh that's not a problem all of a sudden
you go I can't I think cow has to change
here yeah instead of arresting arresting
people and putting them in prison okay
you know they should have been thought
about before Qatar was given the World
Cup I want fans who uh who are gay to be
able to go and enjoy the football like
everyone else I mean I understand that
sort of as a government we have to put
forward quite a soft line to the qataris
but I actually think that you know the
organizers of the World Cup should have
been much more robust even 19 minutes do
a boycott then
but it's not for me to say I'm no longer
a minister but I think we're about to
come on today yeah
cut off right or wrongly is considered a
big Ally they sell us gas and then buy
buy arms uh I think the government has
to be very robust on human rights and
the rights of people uh from England
Wales or anywhere else in the United
Kingdom who go to that World Cup and
defend them if you're gay you should not
be persecuted when you're going to the
World Cup Jerry Kevin boy thank you back
with you shortly next much much more
from Sir Jake Barry speaking out for the
first time since he was sacked and with
the mounting crisis facing the new prime
minister just how will Rishi sooner
Salvage the country's economy
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back it's Jake Berry and Kevin
McGuire is still with us so Jake Berry
you were fired after 50 days and the job
you've always wanted must have hurts but
even the best things must come to an end
Harry it was an amazing opportunity to
work really closely with Liz truss as
prime minister but I accept that you
know there's two real appointments that
are very close to the Prime Minister the
first is the party chairman the second
is the chief whip unfortunately come in
hand out with your prime minister I'd
hoped for a few more days but it was a
great privilege to have the opportunity
to do it you are with Liz trust in those
final final moments in Downing Street
some of those meetings where everything
was thrashed out what was it like in
there what was the mood like I mean when
did she really know that it was over
well look the the former prime minister
was always very chipper
um and she was a fighter not a quitter
as I think she said to Parliament
I think there came a point where she
realized that the the all the newspapers
including ones that are traditionally
supportive of the conservative party had
really made their mind up about her
colleagues had made their mind up about
her and there was no real way of
fighting back and that was compounded uh
that the straw that broke the back of
the very heavily burdened camel was the
chaos that we saw in the division Lobby
over the the fracking boat and it sort
of that felt like the point of no return
it was extraordinary but mistakes have
been made long before then even the very
earliest days of her Premiership when
did you realize it was going south
well I you know I I I kept fighting I
mean there was always the eternal
optimist and I thought you know I think
the danger is with having changed prime
minister now is that I made this point
to colleagues in advance of the change I
think dangerous that the real questions
out there now in the country about
whether we should have a general
election that would be frankly a
catastrophe for the conservative party
and I do support Rishi sunax call to
unite behind him and focus on the
national interest but I think those
questions about when that election will
come will get louder and louder
particularly from opposition parties I
wanted to come to that because you were
responsible for the party's membership
there was a feeling over the last couple
of days that the members have been
ignored and they're the people who
ultimately you're going to ask to vote
for you I mean do you think that
relationship between the Westminster
Party and the conservative membership is
you know can you put it back together or
was it broken now well look we can
always put it back together but I think
it has been severely damaged I was a big
advocate of having a members vote
um I didn't really actually like when we
saw the 1922 committee a sort of all
male panel a bit like the sort of
Chinese politburo grinning saying there
is one candidate and acclaiming that
candidate I would have really liked to
have seen a competition that's not what
my colleagues wanted and the
conservative party was ready in short
order to do an online vote which would
have delayed the process of the
selection of the new prime minister only
by 48 hours I'm sure the members feel
quite angry about that I'm just an
ordinary member of the conservative
party as well as being an MP I would
have liked to have had my say because I
didn't even get a vote in that election
because I was sort of you know in charge
of the election so I you know I think
it's a Pity one person that could have
avoided the talk of the general election
is the man with the Mandate Boris
Johnson you backed him in 2009 19. did
you want him to come back this time well
I backed him in 2016 and 2019 I'm a
long-term friend and Backer of Boris
Johnson I accept actually he probably
wasn't the right time for him to come
back I presume he will have thoughts
about coming back at some future days
but he tried very hard and he led a lot
of people up the hill and you know the
plug out at the last minute while people
still saying he should come back on
television do you think he's
disappointed
Boris Johnson has stood in three
leadership elections and withdrawn from
two of them and it's surely done now
though isn't it well I don't know you
know I think people have got Paul
betting against the bounce back he's the
proverbial rubber ball keeps bouncing
back would you vote for him again
um well okay I have to wait and see
some of the problems that that were
there for Boris Johnson and for Liz
truss are still there for Rishi sunak
and even though your party Feels buoyed
by prime minister's questions today the
reality is it's going to be you know a
difficult couple of months you mentioned
a general election there do you think
it's possible for the party to solve
those issues without one now yeah I do I
mean I thought actually pmqs was the
best uh sort of first outing at pmqs
I've seen in the whatever it is now five
Prime Ministers that I've seen on their
first outing in that role I thought it
was fantastic look whether we like it or
not we don't live in a presidential
country parties get elected parties then
choose their leader and they become
Prime Minister I thought the interesting
thing is that no prime minister since
1974 has come in and out of office by
general election that's a very long time
and it shows that both labor and
conservatives do reserve the right to
change their leader halfway through in
Parliament and just give us an Insight
before we we let you go at least for
this segment what was it like to be
sacked how did that go down yeah a lot I
understand I've known Rishi sunaka a
long time I went in and he gave me a
sort of speech about you know all the
things I'd done which he thought were
great which was nice to hear but then
ultimately you know there just aren't
enough seats around the table for
everyone
you know well I I I'd gone out to bat
for the Prime Minister both during the
the former prime minister both during
the leadership election and in her last
days and Downing streets and that's to
say it was a personal appointment I was
very personally loyal to her I didn't
expect to continue in my role but I do
wish Rishi and his new Team all the best
and I really hope they can unite and win
that general election well Jake Barry
we'll get more from you later on but
some of the issues that we were just
referencing there are of course economic
ones and joining us now for more on that
is Economist Professor Danny blanch
flower who today Outland an alternative
economic plan stating austerity is
something that Britain simply cannot
afford lovely to have you with us at
Professor I support you we've just been
hearing about some of those economic
problems and the fact that there is a 35
5 billion pound black hole to fill for
the government how would you do it
well let's just start and say this that
we've seen calming and we've seen an
improvement in the pound and we've seen
bond yields come down but the economy is
in recession it's there's data we've had
out in the last couple of days saying
basically there's recession coming we
don't know how deep and we don't know
how long and so the problem for this
prime minister is going to be the data
is going to determine everything and
think back to 2008 we're not that
dissimilar by about September 2008 talk
was Raising interest rates and trying to
cut public spending well the reality is
you can't do that in a recession you're
probably going to have to do exactly the
opposite you're probably going to have
to cut interest rates and you're
probably going to have to increase
public spending but there's the Dilemma
on the one hand there's a call to cut
spending on the other there's a call to
basically raise it and if you don't
that's going to be a problem because we
have to talk about how are you going to
cut it I mean if you think of the size
of that number the the UK's defense
budget is about 40 billion pounds so if
you think there's a hole in the finances
of 30 or 40 well where are you going to
cut from so that's obviously the
question and the markets they like what
they've seen on the last couple of days
the question is how is he going to cope
going forward and is he going to show
the great flexibility he showed in 2008
I hope so but this this may well be a
poison chalice because the economics is
going to drive the politics Danny can
you see uh the new prime minister
Michelle who spent a long time saying
he's a tax cutting Chancellor before he
became prime minister can you see him in
any way not having to put up taxes
well it's certainly not a time to put up
taxes I certainly agree with that and I
think that's probably a something he's
going to be able to go along with he's
but he's the question is how is he going
to prevent the economy from collapsing I
mean we had data this week it's really
just come this week made clear so we've
had things called the surveys from
purchasing managers say the UK's entered
recession we've had data on retail sales
and output so the question is does that
get worse does he respond and say well
I'm going to have to scrap the the plan
that I have they've already put it back
a couple of weeks and the reason is they
have to take stock I think if we do this
what's the obr going to say are they
going to say that this is a sensible
thing to do and I think you know it
everything's on the table we're really
going to see if you if you try and go
down the road of cutting public spending
what's the public gonna say what's the
public going to do giving you're so far
behind in the polls and what's the Tory
voter going to say they're not going to
be happy about seeing collapse coming
all around them so I think we're sitting
and wait the markets have responded
positively but each day we're going to
watch and see how the data comes in and
how soon act responds I think his
greatest strength is probably he's shown
that he can be flexible and he's gonna
have to be
the problem is though the reality here
is that by 2026 40 of day-to-day
government spending is going to be going
on the NHS that is a huge amount of
money I mean is that sustainable
well the question is um how else are you
going to pay for it now there are
obviously you ask is it sustainable I
mean the population is aging how are you
going to deal with it so there are a
number of things you can do you can go
use the central bank we propose that in
an article in the Daily Mirror today I
mean the question is what does the
public want you can't sustain it with
the current level of taxes somehow or
other you're going to have to pay for it
and the question is are the public going
to be prepared to do that
um and willitory politician agree to
actually raise taxes to pay for it so
that's the issue do you want to have a
quality public service and it'll cost
you more are you going to keep the
service where you are with seven million
people waiting for operations what are
you going to do so there's a question
the public in a sense has to decide and
I assume the labor party and the Tory
party are going to take different views
on it and in the end the Public's gonna
decide but we're gonna have to get
through a very tough winter and the tour
is of 30 points behind in the polls not
looking as if it's going to get better
Professor blouse flower while I've got
you you've your critics say that you've
predicted two out of the six last
processions now six out of the last two
recessions sorry how confident are you
about this one
well actually in fact in the UK I'll
call the recessions more than better
than anybody else in uh I called it in
April 2008 and nobody else at the bank
of England called it I haven't called a
recession since and I've actually got
papers where I called all five of the
last five in the United States so I
think I actually have the I mean you may
say it's economics is hard and you know
it makes makes astrology look good but
actually I've been pretty darn good at
it and if you read what I said about Sue
about about this trussonomics in July
and August I I nailed it yeah
but I did nail it didn't I yeah you did
I gave it I'll give you that I did it
stay there Danny we're gonna have a chat
with Kevin McGuire and Jake Berry
doesn't sound like good news there does
it no I remember him getting it right in
2008 uh but no look there are no good
choices if you're a Rishi sooner there's
bad and worse and they're going to be
really really difficult choices now
whenever he says it I think it's going
to be your choices are typical for other
people but is he really going to be able
to cut spending he's you're really going
to be increasing taxes he's not in a
political position to do it he'll I
think he'll just dig even deeper the
whole he is in he's got to somehow hold
his nerve and try and get through this I
hope the world economy improves that gas
prices full fuel prices fall so he
spends less than less than he thought
because if he doesn't increase pensions
by the triple lock and he breaks the
link with Benefits Universal Credit half
of which or thereabouts goes to working
people he's he's going to just lose
whatever support that conservatives are
Clinging On to now
Jake your facial expressions during that
interview were a picture I have to say
uh but you were frowning I was laughing
I was laughing at all Harry's jokes but
you were like you were having a little
bit of a giggle but you were frowning
intensely when he was talking about the
economy collapsing I mean you don't
agree that we're at a very soon I mean I
you've got to feel great sympathy for uh
you know for any politician who's having
to make those really difficult decisions
that Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunt are are
having to make it is very very difficult
to get conservative MPS and red wall
constituencies to start voting to break
the link between the pensions the triple
lock to break the link between earnings
and benefit up rating is a really really
difficult scenario but if as the
government has said
that they want debt to be falling as a
proportion of GDP then that you know
they need to have a plan to grow GDP and
we've heard this evening that most of
the supply side reforms are going to be
scrapped as proposed by the former prime
minister Liz truss and if you do all of
that it's hard to see where the growth
is going to come from and then you get
into this sort of death spiral of cuts
and I think that you know we have
learned from the sort of eight nine ten
uh recession 20 2010 recession that you
you can't cut your way to Prosperity so
we need to have a plan and whatever you
know Danny Blanchard may have said about
tristanomics and you know they don't
work or whatever it was at least a plan
to try and grow the economy and the
final thing on tax is look you can't
talk about being the party of low tax if
you're the government of the highest tax
burden for the last 70 years so there
has to be a bit of ankle shown to
hard-working households who sort of are
looking groaning under this burden of
tax we understand it can't come now but
it's got to come in the foreseeable
future and this is the budget that
really sets the time for the next
general election it's a hugely difficult
task for the new prime minister yeah
well someone who clearly isn't worried
about a hugely difficult economic time
is Elon Musk just take a look at what
he's just tweeted in the last few
minutes
that is Elon Musk entering Twitter HQ
his tweet says let that sink in yes you
can see a sink in his hands there man
who loves to joke as much as Harry Cole
does
I mean Kevin what do you make of that
Dale finalized this week we expect
finally well let's let's see what he
does does that mean Trump's back on his
speech can uh run uh I'm talking to the
literally talking to the Kremlin
directly
I find it disturbing I mean he's a
brilliant business person in some ways a
Tesla and so on but in other ways is
frightening Jake well look I mean twist
is a tough neighborhood isn't it but I
think we have to remember that um people
who spend a bit less time on Twitter
whoever owns it reflect Kevin's concern
but one of the great things about no
longer the only great thing about no
longer being part of German is the fact
that I can ignore Twitter well there you
go that's uh one good thing at least
well coming up next A Wish called Rwanda
get it can Sue Ella bravaman in her
second sense at the home office finally
take control of the migrant crisis
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back after a quick reprieve on
the back benches Zoella Braverman is
back as Home Secretary and she'll have
one thing on her mind
I would love to be here saying well
claiming Victory I would love to be
having a front page of the telegraph
with a fly a plane taking off to Rwanda
that's my dream
well this morning the home Affairs
committee had some gobsmacking evidence
just four percent of the migrants across
the channel had their Asylum claims
processed in the last 12 months and 85
of those claims were waved through 16
years after John Reed declared the
department not fit for purpose things
that the home office haven't got much
better
well we're joined Now by Alex shellbrook
Tori MP and former Defense Minister Alec
lovely to have you with us this evening
now I'm sorry to say I'm sorry to say
that you've lost your job in government
and we will come back to that uh in a
moment but I want to start off with
immigration because Sewell government
back at the home office that means the
Rwanda policy very much back on but some
question whether or not it will work as
a deterrent so do you believe it will
will anybody ever be sent to Rwanda
well I think we've got to give this
policy a go and the reason I say that is
because no other policy has worked and
equally for the people who are saying we
shouldn't be doing this they haven't
come up with an alternative either so we
have a massive problem but I do think
today is sort of really important light
on this um discussion is that one of the
biggest problems we face is what's going
on in our own country in our own civil
service and as you rightly pointed out
it's not just this government it's been
the coalition government it's been the
labor government it's been all sorts of
governments because we go back to 2006
where John Reid rightly identified that
the immigration system this country does
not work and really we've got to sort
that out
is Sue Ella braveman the Home Secretary
to do that Mr shelbrook
but she certainly needs to be Harry
um she she's on the right to the party
you played the clip of um what she said
at the Party Conference
um I would expect her to sort this out
she's made it her Mission sub herself
she's a newly appointed home secretary
under a new government
um which started effectively yesterday
um and she's obviously made it her
Mission so as in the Harry Truman the
buck stops here there stops with her and
um she has to make it work but she
equally needs to take a grip of her
Department in the way that John Reed 16
years ago said it should be done because
if we are not deporting people you can
fly them as far as you like but really
it's just 96 of people not process just
shows that the real problem lies in
Whitehall yeah I'm interested that you
say that Alec because you know the stats
there that Harry read out the fact that
we've got you know billions of pounds
worth of money being spent on putting
people up in hotels the conditions in
those hotels not great for the people
who have to stay in them I mean what do
you think has gone wrong and what would
you like to see Rishi sunak actually do
Now quickly to try and put it right
well Kate let me throw a real curveball
at you uh I've never had this discussion
with government but I've certainly had
it with other colleagues is that I would
stick everything which is in the Justice
Department back into the home office and
take everything to do with immigration
out of the home office make it separate
Department because clearly it's an
overwhelming issue and quite frankly it
needs its own Secretary of State for
immigration and the whole department
dealing with just this issue because
quite frankly it just simply isn't
working Alex thank you for joining us
Kevin I want to bring you in on that
point because it is a really interesting
suggestion isn't it do you think it
would solve the problem I don't know I
think it might just be moving people
around White Hall and you would dream
yeah you'd create instability in the
short term the system's going to be made
to work there's no there's no doubt and
I I speak as somebody who's very Pro
migration I think we're enriched as a
country by people come in here but
you've got to have a system that works
and that includes processing claims and
allowing people to come legally because
some of the people coming across the
channel
they're I think more than half of them
are allowed to stay once they are
processed and once they are here but
we're just trying to lock them out and
use the channel as a moat and it's not
working
so Jake Berry you served in the
government missile Braven is she the
right person to fix this well look let's
look at the facts we are currently
spending seven million pounds a day
been in a year housing people in hotel
we'll just think of those seats up and
down the country who'd happily take two
days worth of that money to really
Revitalize the High Street it's not
working and I think we do need a new
approach the first thing I would like to
see us commit to is if you cross the
channel illegally you should be sent
back to France you shouldn't be given
asylum in this country I would like you
know forget planes taking off and going
to Rwanda I'd like to see ferries going
from Dover to Calais or yeah that way
around that's fine David's Calais with
people who've come to this country
illegally we have a proud history of
welcoming people to this country but
there are many legal routes and if
people cross illegally they should be
said well in brevmond though you were
there in the government in in the bunker
at the end when she was fired was it
right that she came back
but six days is a long time in politics
it's for the new prime minister and he
must be free to point to everyone so
look what I would say is
from my own knowledge there were
multiple breaches of the ministerial
code in fact multiple multiple beaches
of the ministerial code it was sent from
a private email address to another
Member of Parliament she then sought to
copy in that individual's wife and
accidentally sent it to a staffer in
Parliament to me that seems a really
serious breach especially when it was
documents relating to cyber security as
I believe that seems a really serious
breach the cabinet secretary had his day
at the time I doubt he's changed his
mind in the last six days but that's a
that's a matter for the new Prime and
did she hold her hands up to it in that
meeting did she admit it well I wasn't I
wasn't in the meeting because I
understand it the evidence was put to
her and she accepted the evidence rather
than the other way around Jake Barry
Kevin McGuire thank you very much still
ahead just 25 days from Qatar 2022 and
with controversy over the country's
record on gay rights hotting up should
players and fans be showing up at all
that's next
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now before we talk about
the World Cup I have to show you this
just take a look at the state of this
desk Harry Cole's side of the desk it's
fine looks like a messy boy's bedroom my
side of the desk and I did not set this
up
a calming music exactly how it ought to
be yes I'd like a little Halo that's
right but welcome back we are heading to
the World Cup now it's happening this
winter now if you are going don't forget
your passport don't forget your tickets
and apparently don't forget to hide your
sexuality after LGBT lgbtq activist
Peter tatchel was yesterday stopped from
protesting against the Gulf States
attitude to gay people foreign secretary
James cleverly this morning advise
visitors to respect the culture of the
host nation
I have spoken to the Qatari authorities
in the past about gay football fans
going to watch the World Cup and how uh
they uh how they will treat our fans and
international fans
um and you know they want to make sure
that football fans are safe secure and
enjoy themselves and they know that that
means that they are going to have to
make some compromises in terms of what
is uh you know an Islamic country with a
very different set of cultural norms to
our own
foreign
good evening Peter what happened with
the Qatari piece police did they arrest
entertain you as you said took us
through it
well I was standing outside the national
museum of Qatar on a main busy road by a
big roundabout for about 35 minutes
before State security and the police
arrived uh while I was protesting there
many members of the public who are
passing by were shocked and gorped in
disbelief that anyone would dare stage a
protest because protests are basically
illegal in Qatar when the security and
police arrived
they took away the placard
they set up as not Freedom leave that I
had to stay there with them so I was
basically detained in their presence on
the curbside for 49 minutes while I was
interrogated at the same time they
spotted that my colleague from the Peter
natural Foundation Simon Harris was
taking photographs and went over to him
and seized his mobile phone and deleted
most of the videos and still photographs
that he'd taken fortunately he'd managed
to upload some of them already so that
the message the images got out
um was very interesting and entertaining
just
I'm just going to say your your the
incidence called major auctions here
back in London the foreign secretary is
saying essentially that gay people
should Reign it in if they travel to
Qatar for the World Cup here's a big
viewer of this show what would you say
to James cleverley tonight
well I was astonished and shocked by
James cleverley's statement it was all
focused on fans respecting the culture
of the host nation there was nothing in
his statement about criticizing the home
nation for its violation of Human Rights
I was also shocked to learn that he
plans to go to the World Cup you know
this is colluding with a homophobic
sexist and racist dictatorship that is
not what we expect of British Home
Secretary to do going to cut off of the
World Cup is like going to the Nazi
Olympics in Berlin in 1936 it gives
kudos to an intensely vile repressive
regime incredibly strong words there
Peter what do you think James cleverly
means by respecting cultural norms what
do you think he expects people to do
when they are in the country
well I can only assume that he expects
people to conform to the way in which
Qatar represses the human rights of
women and LGBT plus people now you know
in Qatar women are not free and equal
citizens you know they have to get
permission from a male Guardian in order
to marry
get certain jobs and to study and travel
abroad that is a total abrogation of
their human rights as a female person
you know James cleverley should be
focusing on those abuses and not expect
that female fans going to the football
World Cup have to behave in a way that
denies women and LGBT plus people the
dignity and respect that they deserve
Peter tatchell thank you for joining us
now joining us in the studio is team
gb's Mark Foster and the times Chief
Sports correspondent Matt Lawton is in
Manchester
Mark lovely to have you with us I just
want to start on those James cleverly
comments I mean how does it make you
feel to hear the UK government
essentially saying compromise who you
are and you know would you be going
um I suppose as Peter mentioned it there
first of all isn't it rather than
stating and having a go at the way that
they are in their country first of all
it was will respect their their rules
which I kind of get in a sense
um but I mean from my point of view as
an athlete I suppose as an athlete or as
a footballer when your whole uh career
has been about representing your country
and going somewhere I don't really I
kind of don't put the onus on the
athletes I'd like to say that they
wouldn't go and Bol ultimately it comes
down to why the FIFA put a championship
there in the first place but as a gay
athlete doesn't that mean you have to
stop being who you are uh well I suppose
well I'm not well for me when I went to
the Olympic Games I didn't it wasn't
about what I was doing in the streets
and I wasn't about you know I was there
to do a job and that was my job so to
speak but I was never put in that
position so I never had and things have
changed an awful lot from when I when
the good thing is we're talking about
this yeah as opposed to uh I wish the
World Cup wasn't there and I wish that
people wouldn't go there and do events
what about they do and it's all about
money but you were talking about the
athletes so far and the politicians what
about the fans do you think the fan
should boycott is that fair on them uh
well it's gonna be interesting isn't it
isn't it isn't there like no drinking
policy and we all know what fans are
like so I wonder how they're going to
actually contain the fans when it comes
to anyway
um does the boycott start with the fans
not going does a boycott start with
people not watching on television back
at home I mean I love the World Cup will
I watch it yeah I probably will just
because I love the world cup but it's
one of those situations whereby I think
unless people do make a stand and that's
what Peter did there by going over and
making a stand and doing a protest which
you shouldn't do unless people do
something and that's always been the
thing with LGBT rights unless someone
does something and stands out and takes
the flat for it nothing changes and
nothing happens
yeah let's bring in uh Matt Lawson and
Manchester Matt you were there that
night that day that uh Qatar won the bid
for the World Cup was it a stitch up
well given the the people that voted on
the FIFA executive committee it was only
a couple of years later in the same
place that they were being dragged out
the hotel with blankets over their heads
by American Federal officers
um yeah you've got to say despite
qatar's denials of any kind of
corruption
um it it doesn't look right we've seen
on so many occasions that these major
sporting events the process by which
they are awarded has been corrupted and
it it absolutely stunk at the time I
remember standing at the bottom of the
steps of the borolac hotel in Zurich and
William uh David Cameron Prince William
David Cameron and David Beckham coming
down the stairs and they you could tell
they thought they they had it in the bag
and the next day they got one vote
so um it's look I agree with Mark and
Peter it shouldn't be there that this
decision was made 12 years ago when
people like Harry Kane were still at
school they shouldn't be the ones that
are punished for it but I tell you what
depresses me about it is the fact that I
I I interviewed the the head of the
World Cup organizing Committee in Doha
three years ago and at that time he was
talking about
an effort being made to be more
inclusive an effort being made to
educate people in Qatar police officers
and so on about being more more
understanding about about people and I
got the impression then that if two men
were walking down the street in Doha
during the World Cup holding hands that
people would understand that that they
had visitors from around the world yeah
but now the messaging is very much that
that won't be tolerated
Matt Lawton Mark Foster thank you both
so much for joining us an absolutely
fascinating discussion and one that will
no doubt be brought into politics in the
next couple of days but that is it from
us tonight thank you all so much for
watching and whatever you're doing I'm
told to say make sure it's uncensored
good night
[Music]
foreign
foreign